Ben Affleck shocking the internet with
his impressive Spanish skills you know
it's wild to think about it that way a
recent clip of the actor talking about
his new film air is going viral because
some fans didn't know his conversational
Spanish is on point this is
while it came as a revelation to many
it's not the first time Ben shared he's
bilingual is it true that you speak
Spanish like fluently I would say
passively passively yes but I got like a
little bit of cool bandwidth now yeah
during a visit to the Kelly Clarkson
show a few years back the Stars spilled
all of about how he picked up the
language so seamlessly I mean I did this
like a little kids TV series when I was
young and when I was 13 That season that
year was in Mexico yeah so I was in
Mexico for a year and and that's how I
that's how I picked it up it's really
quite an experience no doubt Ben's
taught his kids a little thing or two
about Spanish but he claimed his
daughter's expertise might have passed
him up all of a sudden she got into the
grade where she's like in the harder
Spanish classes and she's getting better
and I and she's like right at the point
where I think she might be passing me
and that's why I was like nope this is
not happening I don't mind that I can't
do your math homework if you're 14 years
old you are not going to be better at
Spanish than me at the time Ben declared
he wasn't letting that happen so I've
decided now I gotta like take classes I
gotta do something gotta get a tutor to
keep up because I can't have my Fortuner
she was like that sounds ridiculous
you're not using the impre the imperfect
tense I know two tenses now
before the future that's all you need
well those classes are sure to come in
handy at the Affleck household Ben's
currently married to Jennifer Lopez
who's a Puerto Rican descent and often
sings in Spanish too
[Music]
people
okay and let's not forget about the role
that skyrocketed JLo's career her
portrayal of the queen of Tejano music
Selena
[Music]
[Applause]
While most of the world is still reeling
over Ben's ease with the language
according to him not everyone's too
impressed also the problem with Spanish
is that you learn a bunch of words like
I learn all these words yeah in Mexico
some good some you know yeah
and then you go somewhere else like you
go to Spain or you go South America and
they're like no that's not Spanish and
I'm like we're talking about it's not
Spanish well like I've never heard that
word before in my life and it's just
like they say it in Mexico in Mexico
they don't speak real Spanish and then
they allow like you have a Mexican
accent
is magnifico
foreign